later he is accused of shooting cheng
yen wang remains hospitalized tonight
the asian community development council
addressing their support for weighing at
shanghai taste that's where we find
madison kimbrough joining us now live
with more madison
the asian community development council
alongside the asian chamber spoke with
nevada governor silac right here at
shanghai plaza in support of chang wong
and the restaurant where he worked
it was announced that the groups will
continue to raise money for chen yang
wang and also launch a fundraising
campaign to raise up to 10 thousand
dollars for wang's recovery this is wang
in the hospital just a couple days ago
one of the owners of shanghai taste
confirmed that he is now able to eat
solid food but still has a long road
ahead of him governor sisalak made a
contribution of his own to help wang
last week the first lady and i were
honored to contribute to one of those
funds
set up in mr wang's honor when the first
lady and i heard of this senseless
tragedy we were shocked and saddened
today we're all here in support of the
aapi community the governor also
acknowledged the difficulties the asian
community has seen through this pandemic
and announced a small business grant
program to help businesses like shanghai
taste within the community
wang had been living in las vegas a
short time and was working here at
shanghai taste supporting his family in
china now in the overnight hours last
monday he was cleaning the restaurant
when the burglary occurred we're hoping
for a speedy recovery for wang reporting
live in chinatown madison kimbrough live
local now